all right let's back away from politics
for just a second and focus on the fact
that you work at Georgetown University
you're in the midst of this college
situation that everyone's talking about
now we hear about trigger warnings every
day and safe spaces and all of this
stuff so I'm curious as someone that's
in the thick of it have you seen an
attitude change within the student
population where they really are afraid
of new ideas I honestly haven't really
seen this
I do think law schools are different
right than undergraduate programs and so
most of what I know about what you're
talking about I know the way you know it
from reading press accounts of it not
from personal experience I don't exactly
know why I mean it's not that law
schools are completely immune and we do
have our controversies and people can
get themselves into trouble but I just
haven't seen and students do tend to
select professors on the basis of
whether they like and there may be some
students who avoid taking me because
they don't want to be they don't they
don't think I they want to hear from me
but that's their choice and that's a
leaking self-censor that's always been
the case I haven't had a problem and I
haven't seen a problem and I haven't
even heard about that many problems in
law schools themselves yeah so I think
mainly because students who go to law
school are usually interested in a
degree by which they'll make their
living and the professors who teach in
law schools usually are practicing
lawyers are they've been practicing
lawyers they have and they're somewhat
more grounded in the subjects that we
teach contracts property torts what a
simple procedure whatever it is we're
teaching there's a law there right that
we need to talk about it isn't just our
views of what good and bad things are
right so there's sort of a literalness
to it that you wouldn't be able to use a
safe space for because you have to
address the things that you're talking
about as opposed to like a social
science or something I mean there were
problems that when people were teaching
the law of rape and criminal law as to
how they would teach it and and and I
think we've all become more sensitive to
how we express ourselves I mean you have
to be in doing a television or
video thing you have to be more
sensitive to the way you express
yourselves and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that
and so in some respects it's been an
improvement but as long as I think
you're respectful I haven't seen a major
problem I'm hoping that remains the same
for but we'll see yeah I'm curious right
before we took a tiny little break here
you mentioned something about sort of
educational system in general that we
should be teaching kids a lot of these
principals probably a lot younger so
that they get to college I think was the
thrust of what you're saying so they
have some of this knowledge within them
have you seen that change I mean you
know we know our education system in
this country isn't that great
have you seen again you're at a law
school so you're they're already gone
through some years of college but just
sort of the the general state of
education by the time they get to you do
sense that that's changed I haven't
actually even I can't I have to say what
I was joking about is it wouldn't mean I
think wouldn't it be nice if we actually
had a system called a educational system
which people would learn these basics
crazy but the thing is is when I went I
was a public school graduate I graduated
high school I hate to admit this I
graduated high school in 1970 so I went
I was in high school from 66 to 70 I
didn't learn anything much of anything
nothing
not much I mean I got to Kyra member
specifically knowing when I became a
philosophy major in college at
Northwestern and I said and I was taking
other courses and I thought you know
what I could have handled why didn't
they teach me some of this in high
school I was I could have gotten it they
were teaching me blah blah blah and now
I'm starting to learn stuff now in
college so I do think that college is
where you tend if you're going to pick
up real information you do pick it up in
college and by the time they get to law
school they've had college and I teach a
good law schools and students I have
good students to get into the Georgetown
have to do very well and in college and
as a result I think my students are
pretty well educated does that mean they
know everything I think they ought to
know but the truth is I don't know
everything I think I don't know I'm
there I just was teaching con law
constitutional law yesterday and I was
criticizing the casebook for getting
some of the facts wrong you know who
authored the case book Oh me yeah
haha and I was saying to my students I
said I you know I said like I hate court
case book authors that make these stupid
mistakes yeah but it was a writ you know
my own case book I have learned stuff
since I wrote that edition of the case
book that how the case books going to
have to did you figure it out while you
were talking about it or did you know
you knew before is that you were I
walked into the classroom I knew I had
changed my mind or I knew more about
what I was a story I was telling about
the Civil War and stuff in this case
book and I knew more I didn't learn more
about it since I did that addition to
the case book so even now even I had got
stuff wrong in the book right how do we
make this stuff cooler I think that's
the the hurdle here is that when I've
talked to a bunch of guys that I've had
on and we've talked about these ideas
and liberty and individualism and free
speech and all these things but they
don't seem very they're not in the ether
right now as cool ideas the collective
seems to be out there more you know what
I've been calling the oppression
Olympics that everyone wants to be part
of a group that's more oppressed than
some other group but how do we get back
to making some of this stuff cool not
just that so it's not just done as an
intellectual exercise or academic you're
talking to the wrong yes I'm asking the
right guy without I was a nerd yeah
growing up yeah I'm still a nerd I'm a
professor I'm still a nerd I'm not the
guy to tell you talk about cool yeah you
got just as these stuff I know about but
being cool that's not my thing yeah not
not something I know much about yeah
admit you're not cool it's kind of cool
that's how cool this work all right so
let's back up all the way to the
beginning because there was something I
wanted to ask you right up top that we
that we went past which is all right so
you love this document the Constitution
as you said the things that you would
like to see change could all be done
within the constructs although you're
mentioning some other amendments but
they could basically be done within the
constructs of the Constitution is there
any flaw in there that you really see
that were that we're missing or that
really is a weakness of our system well
first of all let me just say I like the
Constitution I mean I don't know if I
love the Constitution but I like it
married okay and and that puts me ahead
of most of my colleagues
don't like the Constitution they don't
like the one we've got they want to make
a different one right so is that true
most of your colleagues I think that's
true that's that's the only reason why
you'd be a living constitutionalist is
because you don't actually like the
document so you want to live your way
evolve your way out of it
so I kind of like it but whether I love
it or not is another question now having
corrected that what was the rest of the
question I forgot there a flaw in it
yeah there were some pieces that you
like it has it hasn't actually worked
out the way it was supposed to it was
supposed to be a charter of limited
government do we have a limited
government now we don't know we
definitely don't so there's something
about it that hasn't worked so well or
we wouldn't be where we were in fact
when I was a law student
I liked the Constitution as a entering
law student and I took constitutional
law and as I got to each part of the
clause of the Constitution I liked I
would turn the page and I would find the
Supreme Court said it doesn't mean what
it's supposed to mean I don't turn the
page this doesn't apply that doesn't
apply that Ninth Amendment thing I read
to you I recited to you earlier that's a
non-starter nobody the court doesn't pay
any attention to the ninth amendment so
my conclusion after taking
constitutional law is if the Supreme
Court doesn't care about the
Constitution why should I so I was done
with the Constitution I went on to be a
criminal prosecutor in Chicago and when
I came it became a law professor I was a
contracts professor not a constitutional
law professor because in contracts the
law still matters writing still matters
and then I got dragged into
constitutional law reluctantly and
that's a long story we don't we no
longer have any time for yeah I got
dragged into it and and so now I spend
almost all my time talking about the
Constitution why because I think the
Constitution that we have the written
constitution as a that has not been
repealed is a better form of government
than the one we currently have and so
that's the flaw in that it's not living
up to it yes yes and so I instead of
arguing only for libertarian first
principles which I also believe in and I
have a book called the structure of
Liberty which argues for instead of just
arguing for libertarian first principles
I think it's worth my time to talk about
this text of the Constitution that is
better and it's not a perfectly
libertarian document but it's more
libertarian than the actual government
that currently we have and so because it
hasn't been repealed I feel like I can
still talk about it and that's
why I do yeah well I have to say I
thoroughly enjoyed this and we laid out
a lot of the principles and the
definitions that I'm constantly talking
about so we're gonna link to all your
books right down butter if ik do you
have a final thought I think we I think
did we did pretty well now I'm gonna go
hit kick back and enjoy my afternoon in
LA before I head back to DC where I
think it was supposed to be 97 degrees
today so I want to thank Randy Barnett
for joining me today on the Rubin report
you can check out his book our
republican constitution in the link
right down below and stay tuned for our
next collaboration with learn liberty
coming next month